体罰が違法であるという法律を見せてくれ
んよねじゃあ体罰を定義してくれよと我々
は体罰しても構わんだから検察を信じたら
いかんのよ俺が日本の裁判やねバスコが
裁判やって学校の先生でさえも生徒しかれ
んようになったよ体罰なしではああいう
子供たちは助からん
から民主主義というのは権力の交代性の
ことや大きな群に力者は絶対に必要ないや
ないとまとまらんのやところが権力は必ず
腐るというのがこれが心理ない今まで
ずっとそうやったからねだったら腐った時
に今までは革命を起こしとったわけやろ
フランス革命が中国の革命代そうすると
国力が低下しちゃうやないか国力が低下し
てる間によそからやられちまう恐れがある
もんで革命を起こさなくてもいいよに国民
自体が権力者を交代させすることができる
ようにした制度これが民主主義ねだから
民主主義というのは反権力で出来上がっ
とるんや権力に対する疑問権力者に対する
疑問権力者を信じないそれで出来上がっ
とる
んまこ見てみ自民党の攻撃ばっかりする
じゃん裁判官の攻撃するしないよねだから
馬鹿なんや日本みたいに裁判が
むちゃくちゃな国ないやろこんなも裁判
なっとえへんよ日本のやつはから独立して
ないや検察が言ったからそれが正しいんだ
なって平気で裁判官が言うんやけどで検察
の方は自分の正しさまそんに書いてった
ぞっていう見むちゃくちゃないよもうこれ
もうみんな基本を知らんから
ね裁判のことトライアルっていうやろ
トライアルテストやろ何のテストか知っ
てる裁判所は何をテストするの審理正しい
かどうか心理をテストするにはないんよ
検察がその被告に対してこれだけの罰を
与えたいと言って要求してくるわけその
許可を出すのが裁判所ねだからそれだけの
罪を犯したこれが真実だというのを検察が
証明せないかの証拠によってその検察を
トライアルするのだから検察を信じたら
いかんのや裁判所は警察を嘘言っとると
思わないかんねところが日本の裁判官見て
みんな警察が正しくて被告の言ったことは
言い訳にすぎんというこれで成り立っとる
に
の裁判見てごらん検察としてはマスコミの
言う通りの罪2000ことには検察文句
言われるんやマスコミにねうちの場合は
違法な体罰をしたから法律違反なという
ことで逮捕場が出て我々は逮捕されてさあ
取の時にねこう言ったね体罰が違法である
という法律を見せてくれのもないや我々は
体罰しても構わんのよ学校教育法の中に
あるだけだからから我々は不利なことを
承知の上で学校法人にならなかったやない
か学校教育法に縛られたら体罰ができない
体罰なしではああいう子供たちは助からん
からえそれなのにマスコミはバカだからね
ともかく自分のお松の知識が全てやと思っ
とるのに体罰は違法に決まっとるんだその
違法の体罰をしたからあいつらは有罪なん
だというそういう論調でずっとやってきた
もんで今更もう危険ようになっておるで
警察がそれに乗っかっちまったもんでえ
違法な対としたということで裁判所から
逮捕場を取っちゃって裁判所もよく調べず
に逮捕場を出ししまったの体罰が違法じゃ
ないということがわから
ん結局逮捕場自体が向こうないで捕まえ
といてから俺にそう言われてなお前ら
間違ってないかいど大騒ぎになってな反田
しというとこや検察とも連絡がして県警
とも大沢ごったししまってそれで我々は
逮捕されてあそこに連れて行かれてその
ほったらかしよ先進めへんねその法律が
ないんやもんねそれで結局奴らの出した
結論というのは実はあれは体罰じゃなかっ
たんや単なる暴行だったんだだから我々は
逮捕したに変えたいそうしたらね次はこう
なるわけじゃあ体罰も定義してくれよとで
ね3日経って何でもただ放り込んどくだけ
で3日経っちまって裁判所も困っとるもん
で3日目に今度は交流新聞っていうのが
あるこれ以上交流しとくか社交するかと
いうでその裁判の時にあなたのやってた
ことは教育ではありませんでした体罰じゃ
なしに暴行だと言ったわけよねだから私は
あなたを交流することに決めましたって
いう若い裁判官
や若い主催独特の可なやつよねあんたな
教育の定義してみどうしてですか教育の
定義ができないやがどうして教育じゃない
と定義できたやそれおかしいと思わんか最
万感のともあろうも
と考え込んじまってねただこっちじーっと
待っとるだけともかく待たせるわな自分
たちが分かってないことやっとるもんで
あんまり待たせるもんでこの初期にこう
やってこいつ大丈夫か言って聞いたらいつ
もそうねカッと顔上げて言ったことが私は
教育については分かりませんだけど交流は
できますそんなもちじゃなそれじゃ法律
違反じゃこれが日本の裁判やねマスコミが
裁判やってるからもう俺が文化けってバカ
なのっていうのは分かるやろそんなこと
ばっかりやそれで日本ダメにし
て結局マスコミは自分の言ってることが
分かってないんやこれ何言ったのかなと
分からんけどともかくこうだという世間
一般の常識がそうだからだけどその常識を
作ったのはマスコミないよね特にその先
きっぱり俺は仲裁だから最先端を走るんだ
という馬鹿やねジフがあるから力もないの
によそでアメリカで例えばパワハラという
言葉が流行り出すと急いでそれを入れて
日本でそれに当たるようなものを本当か
どうかわからずと探し出してきてパ原だと
大騒ぎしてそのやったやつを人生を壊し
ちまうやろセクハパワハラみんなよそから
持ってきた言葉を使って人を責めるという
時は本当に怪しいんや分からずにやっとく
でその結果学校の先生でさえも生徒を敷か
れんようになった
やろ子供を叱らない叱ってはいかんになっ
たわね大妻女子の平井の武が光るより
褒めろという言葉をアメリカから輸入して
これが正しいんだ言って流行らししまった
マスクはいこぶりこだからうわーとそれを
私はいい室だから子供叱らない日本に使い
出してで今度は悪いやつを作らんと自分が
いい室だということ分からんもんでね
あいつはしったからとんでもないやつだと
いう学校の先生やめさしたり教育委員会
やめさせたりそういうバカなことばっかり
やった自分を目立たせるために人を没落さ
せるあれがマスコミのやり方よその中の光
より褒めろのいつく先は体罰絶対反対に
なるんやとんでもないことやなんで体罰は
いかんのタバって何なんそれは知らんけど
ともかくいかむちゃくちゃないんよ理論に
なってない人間的な知性のかけらも
なくなっちまってるんよマスコミの言う
ことは
ねDET